This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. People in romantic relationships often share things in common. A love with the same sports team, maybe the same religion, sometimes a common profession. But for some couples, the similarities go further. The girl that I am dating now, we have a same birthday. This is kind of cool. My fiance, Israel and I have the same birthday,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。处于浪漫关系中的人们往往有许多共同点。热爱同一支运动球队，或许有相同的宗教信仰，有时甚至是相同的职业。但对一些伴侣来说，这种相似性还不止于此。我现在约会的这个女孩，我们同年同月同日生。这真是太酷了。我和我的未婚夫伊斯雷尔同一天生日，
which is something we discovered on our second date. You could say this isn't so surprising. There are lots of people in the world, and soon or a later, some people are going to get together with others who happen to have the same birthday. But there's evidence this may be more than just a coincidence. Having a common birthday seems to actually draw people closer to one another. When I first went to a new hairstyles, we found out that we had the same birthday and we called each other birthday twins. And I wound up going to that hairstyles for years, even after she switched to runs, even after we moved.
这是我们在第二次约会上发现的。你可能会觉得这并不那么令人意外。世界上有那么多人，总有一天，有些人会和恰好在同一天生日的人走到一起。但有证据表明，这可能不仅仅是巧合。拥有共同的生日似乎真的能把人们拉得更近。当我第一次去一家新的发廊时，我们发现我们同一天生日，我们称彼此为“生日双胞胎”。结果我在那家发廊剪了好几年头发，甚至在她换了地方之后，甚至在我们搬家之后也是如此。
I would drive 40 minutes to go get my hair cut by her. Some people see so much significance in shared birthdays or even shared numbers in two birthdays that they select dates for important events based on those patterns. My birthday is August 2nd and my husband Blake's birthday is August 9th and we got married on August 29th. My wife and I share the same birthday to life six and we are also married on that day. My birthday is October 27th and with my first husband, his birthday was September 27th and we had the opportunity to get married on August 27th.
我会驱车40分钟去找她理发。有些人认为共同的生日，甚至两个生日中包含的相同数字具有如此重要的意义，以至于他们根据这些规律来选择重要活动的日期。我的生日是8月2日，我丈夫布莱克的生日是8月9日，我们在8月29日结了婚。我和我妻子在6月6日过同样的生日，我们也是在那天结的婚。我的生日是10月27日，我的第一任丈夫，他的生日是9月27日，而我们有机会在8月27日结婚。
It was a no-brainer. We decided to do that. The woman you just heard, genetic cravings from Oklahoma City, says her love for people with the same birthday extends beyond her love life. On October 27th, is also Teddy Roosevelt birthday and so I've always felt a little affinity for him and for his leadership.
这根本不用想。我们决定就这么办。你刚才听到的那位来自俄克拉荷马城的珍妮塔·克雷文斯（Genetic Cravings），她说她对同年同月同日生的人的喜爱已经超出了她的爱情生活。10月27日也是西奥多·罗斯福的生日，所以我一直对他以及他的领导力有一种天然的好感。
Shared birthdays, in fact, aren't the only thing that draw people closer to one another. Janetta also finds herself drawn to people who happen to have the same name. When I meet another geneta, there's an automatic, like, oh my gosh, I can't believe we have the same name. And then it happens to be that we have the same spelling.
事实上，共同的生日并不是唯一能把人们拉近的因素。珍妮塔还发现自己会被那些恰好与自己同名的人吸引。当我遇到另一个珍妮塔时，会有一种本能的反应，比如，噢天哪，我真不敢相信我们同名。然后巧合的是，我们连拼写都一样。
And I'll tell you, you've only met two people who have the same spelling of me, but I can tell you who they are, and I I felt an automatic kinship. These unexpected connections with strangers can be lovely moments, but there's something else at work to, something we may not be aware of, something that affects all of us. In Greek mythology, the hunter Narcissus was so enamored of his own beauty that he fell in love with the reflection of himself. Modern psychology shows that we all have a little bit of Narcissus in us, most of us like people who remind us of ourselves, whether that someone else with the same name or someone with the same birthday. Most of the time, such self-love is amusing and harmless, maybe even beneficial, a sign of good
而且我告诉你，你只见过两个和我拼写完全一样的人，但我能告诉你他们是谁，而且我感觉到了一种天然的亲切感。与陌生人的这些意外连接可能会带来美好的时刻，但背后还有别的东西在起作用，有些我们可能没有意识到，有些会影响我们所有人的东西。在希腊神话中，美少年纳喀索斯对自己的美貌如此着迷，以至于他爱上了自己在水中的倒影。现代心理学表明，我们每个人的内心深处都有点纳喀索斯的影子，我们大多数人都喜欢那些能让我们想起自己的人，无论是同名的人还是同一天生日的人。大多数时候，这种自恋是有趣且无害的，甚至可能是有益的，是良好
self-esteem. But there are times when falling in love with ourselves or with people who remind us of ourselves, can be a real problem. This week on Hidden Brain, what we are calling the Narcissus Effect. Researcher of Long Observed Attendancy for People to be drawn to others who I like them in some way. When we hear someone else has the same birthday or the same name, we feel a little tug of kinship. Some of us might even be drawn to move to states that sound familiar. There's at least a modest tendency for women named Georgia to gravitate toward Georgia,
自尊的表现。但有时，爱上我们自己，或者爱上那些让我们想起自己的人，可能会成为真正的问题。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们探讨所谓的“纳喀索斯效应”。研究人员长期以来一直观察到这样一种倾向：人们会被那些在某些方面与自己相似的人所吸引。当我们听说别人和自己同一天生日或同名时，我们会感受到一丝亲切感的牵引。我们中的有些人甚至可能会被吸引去搬到那些听起来很熟悉的州。名叫乔治亚的女性对乔治亚州有一种微弱的倾向，
women named Virginia, to gravitate toward Virginia, and the more closely the name resembles a state the bigger the effect appears to be. This is Brett Pellam. He's a professor of psychology at Montgomery College in Maryland. He studied something called implicit egotism, which is the idea that many biases are unconscious and one very well studied bias was egotism, valuing the self favorably, protecting the self and so forth. And so we simply got the idea that there are several different things that at least some degree reflect a preference for the self and an attraction to things that resemble the self. Like having an affinity for someone with the same birthday or someone with the same name.
名叫弗吉尼亚的女性对弗吉尼亚州也有这种倾向，而且名字与某个州的相似度越高，这种效应似乎就越明显。这是布雷特·佩拉姆（Brett Pelham）。他是马里兰州蒙哥马利学院的心理学教授。他研究过一种叫做“内隐自负”（implicit egotism）的现象，这个概念是指许多偏见都是无意识的，其中一个被深入研究的偏见就是自负，即对自我给予正面评价、保护自我等等。因此，我们很自然地想到，有几种不同的行为在某种程度上反映了对自我的偏好以及对与自我相似事物的吸引力。比如对同一天生日的人或同名的人产生好感。
Or even going into a profession that sounds like an echo of your name. So we originally looked at whether people named Dennis or Denise gravitate toward dentistry, but we learned pretty quickly that it's really hard to get data on those things. So, you know, there aren't great directories of medical professionals. There is a guy named Abel who was able to document, and I was a reviewer on this paper. So, now every time you see this, I'm gonna jump in and say a guy named Abel who was able to do something. He was able to do a lot of things. He showed that people whose last name is Doctor, or whose last name is the word lawyer, the name lawyer,
甚至从事一个听起来像你名字回响的职业。所以我们最初研究名叫丹尼斯（Dennis）或丹尼斯（Denise）的人是否倾向于从事牙医行业（dentistry），但我们很快发现，很难获得这些方面的数据。所以，你知道，并没有医学专业人员的优秀名录。有一个名叫阿贝尔（Abel）的人成功进行了记录，而我是这篇论文的审稿人。所以，现在每当你看到这个时，我都要跳出来说，有一个叫阿贝尔的人做成了这件事。他确实做了很多事。他发现姓氏是“医生”（Doctor），或者姓氏是“律师”这个词、也就是名字叫“律师”的人，
gravitated toward those two professions. There are lots of other examples. Brett looked at a massive database of millions of Americans, names from the recently released 1940 census, to examine if they were brought patterns. Like Carpenter's working in Carpentry, Bakers working as Bakers, butchers working as butchers. Miners working as minor mason's working as mason So we looked at every surname there is Currently the top 2000 surnames that happens to be a career name And we looked at all of them. They're 11 of them that are pretty common
会倾向于这两个职业。还有很多其他的例子。布雷特查阅了一个包含数百万美国人的庞大数据库，这些名字来自最近发布的1940年人口普查数据，以检查是否存在广泛的规律。比如木匠（Carpenter）从事木匠工作，面包师（Baker）从事面包师工作，屠夫（Butcher）从事屠夫工作。矿工（Miner）从事采矿，石匠（Mason）从事石匠工作。所以我们查看了现有的每一个姓氏，在前2000个姓氏中，恰好有职业姓氏的
I just listed a few and for every single surname in the 1940s census with something like a I think it was 130 million people. We were able to show that for every single surname there was at least a weak tendency for people to gravitate toward careers that perfectly matched their last names. So the obvious thing to say of course is that the reason you have a slightly larger number of carpenters, B carpenters is that the name Carpenter probably originated from families who were in carpentry. And so there is some kind of ancestral connection to the profession that is driving both the
我们都研究了。其中有11个是相当普遍的。我刚刚列举了几个，在1940年人口普查中，对于每一个有类似姓氏的人——我想当时大约有1.3亿人——我们都能够证明，对于每一个姓氏来说，人们都至少存在一种微弱的倾向，会倾向于选择与他们姓氏完美匹配的职业。所以显而易见要说的是，当然，姓卡彭特（Carpenter）的人之所以稍微多一点，是因为卡彭特这个姓氏可能起源于从事木工的家族。因此，存在某种将名字和选择联系起来的祖先渊源。
names and the choices. Quite possibly, but if you do the math, you pretty quickly see it gets to be a pretty tiny percentage of people. So if you assume that even over 10 generations, there's a 50% chance that you did what your dad did and a 50% chance that you did what your dad did and a 50% chance that he did what his grandfather did, which is probably higher than reality. You're talking about a probability of less than one in a thousand already over 10 generations. In other words, surnames are so old and they change hands.
很有可能，但如果你算一下数学，你很快就会发现这只占极小比例的人口。所以，假设即使经过10代人，你有50%的概率做你父亲做过的事，有50%的概率做你父亲做过的事，还有50%的概率做你祖父做过的事——这可能比现实情况要高。在10代人之后，其概率已经低于千分之一了。换句话说，姓氏的历史非常悠久，而且会发生流转。
You know, when a woman named Carpenter, Mary's account name, Farmer, for example, that that's really, it really just can't account for an effect anywhere near this magnitude. Brett Palem is looked at large data sets and public records like the Social Security Death Index or State Marriage Records, databases with information about millions of Americans, and he and his fellow researchers have seen all kinds of funny effects. Like for example, one listener called in to say she and her husband were both born on the 25th day of different months.
你知道的，当一个叫卡彭特的女性嫁给一个姓农民（Farmer）的人时，这真的，这真的无法解释这种规模的效应。布雷特·佩拉姆研究过庞大的数据集和公共记录，比如社会保障死亡指数或州婚姻记录，这些数据库包含数百万美国人的信息，他和他的研究同行们看到了各种有趣的效应。比如，曾经有一位听真众打电话来说，她和她的丈夫都在不同月份的25日出生。
This isn't as uncommon as you might think. Beyond what you might expect by your chance, there's about a 7% bias in that direction, so if you should have a thousand people doing that, you have a thousand seventy people doing that. If that doesn't sound like a lot, you're right. You should think of implicit ecotism as a tiny invisible nudge. It won't shape what everyone does all the time, but it does shape what some people do, some of the time.
这并不像你想象的那么罕见。除了随机巧合的预期之外，这个方向大约有7%的偏差，所以如果你有一千人在做这件事，你就会有一千零七十人在做这件事。如果这听起来不算多，你是对的。你应该把内隐自负看作是一种微小而无形的轻推。它不会在所有时间塑造所有人的行为，但它确实在某些时间塑造了某些人的行为。
It's when you multiply these small effects over hundreds of millions of people that you start to see lots of examples. Brett says that if you really love your birthday, the effect gets even larger. Our operational definition of really loving your birthday was getting married on your birthday number. So if you got married on the 13th of the month, you were quite a bit more likely to marry another person who also had the number 13 s's birthday number. Again, Brett calls this an implicit bias for a reason. You may not be consciously choosing things as important as your spouse or your profession or the place you call home based on arbitrary factors like your name or your birthday. He thinks the bias comes about simply because
当你把这些微小的效应乘以数亿人时，你就会开始看到大量的例子。布雷特说，如果你真的很喜欢自己的生日，这种效应会变得更大。我们对“真正喜欢自己的生日”的操作定义是在你的生日数字当天结婚。因此，如果你在每月的13号结婚，你更有可能与另一个生日数字也是13号的人结婚。再次强调，布雷特把这称为内隐偏见是有原因的。你可能没有有意识地根据名字或生日等任意因素来选择诸如配偶、职业或称之为家的地方这样重要的事情。他认为这种偏见的产生仅仅是因为
we like our names in our birthdays and have positive associations with them. And so you just associate your name with all the wonderful things that come along with that. And the best bit of evidence I have that I've never bothered to publish is there's one part of people's names they don't like that much and that's their middle names. You know, the joke about that is the sole purpose of a child's middle name is to know when he's really in trouble. And my additional comment is to know if he might be a serial killer someday, right? So the middle name is not nearly as loved as the first or the last name. People feel very ambivalent about their middle name. They can be other reasons for ambivalence.
我们喜欢自己的名字和生日，并对它们抱有积极的联想。因此，你会把你的名字与随之而来的所有美好事物联系起来。我拥有的从未费心发表过的最好证据是，人们对名字中有一部分并不是那么喜欢，那就是他们的中间名（middle names）。你知道，关于这个有个笑话，小孩子中间名的唯一目的就是让他在真的惹上麻烦时知道。而我的额外评论是，看他将来会不会成为连环杀手，对吧？所以中间名远不像名或姓那样受人喜爱。人们对自己的中间名抱有一种复杂的态度。产生这种复杂态度的原因可能还有其他。
Sometimes we dislike it when another person has the same birthday. If you were born on April 20th, you might hate the fact Hitler was born on that day too. Brett finds that if a consumer product happens to have your name on it, but is poorly built, you are more likely to hate that product. People dislike seeing something inferior in the world that has their name on it. As Brett and I were talking, I realized something a little uncomfortable, that I myself had fallen prey to implicit ecotism. You know, as you're talking right now, I'm realizing something about myself for the very
有时，当另一个人和我们同一天生日时，我们会不喜欢。如果你在4月20日出生，你可能会讨厌希特勒也是在那天出生这一事实。布雷特发现，如果某个消费品恰好带有你的名字，但做工粗糙，你更有可能会讨厌那个产品。人们不喜欢看到世界上出现带有自己名字的劣质东西。正当我和布雷特交谈时，我意识到了一件有点让人不安的事——我自己也成了内隐自负的牺牲品。你知道，就在你刚才说话的时候，我第一次
first time, there was a philosopher in India whose name was Shankara, my name, and he actually taught a philosophy that is known as Vedanta. And I've always been drawn to the fact that I find the philosophy of Vedanta to be very interesting and the fact that Shankara taught that philosophy, I thought was just charming. But now as I'm listening to you say this, I'm realizing that this could just be implicit equities. I've read his work very well and it truly is wonderful. It's brilliant. So I think in this case you make the objectively good decision. Yeah, at the same time it does make you think though.
意识到关于我自己的某些事情，印度有一位哲学家名叫尚卡拉（Shankara），和我的名字一样，他实际上传授了一种被称为“吠檀多”（Vedanta）的哲学。我一直被这样一个事实吸引：我发现吠檀多的哲学非常有趣，而尚卡拉传授了这种哲学，我觉得这简直太迷人了。但现在当我听你这么说时，我意识到这可能只是内隐自负在作祟。我把他的作品读得很好，它确实非常棒。它太精彩了。所以我想在这种情况下，你做出了一个客观上正确的决定。是的，但与此同时它确实也让人深思。
Absolutely, yes. Has this ever happened to you, Brett? Do you ever think about yourself and how implicit ecotism is affecting you? We're getting a little personal here, but I can't resist being a little bit personal. I would say that probably the most dramatic example is that my son Matthew, his last thing is Poland. His mother's that my son Matthew, his last name is Poland, his mother's last name was Poland, my last name is Pelham, and I entered a relationship with her before I developed this theory, not after I developed the theory to validate the theory.
绝对是这样。布雷特，这种事在你身上发生过吗？你有没有想过你自己以及内隐自负是如何影响你的？我们在这里讨论得有点私密了，但我忍不住要说一点私密的事。我想说，最戏剧性的例子可能就是我的儿子马修，他的姓氏是波兰（Poland）。他的母亲——我儿子马修的姓氏是波兰，他母亲的姓氏是波兰，我的姓氏是佩拉姆（Pelham），我在发展出这个理论之前就和她确立了恋爱关系，而不是为了验证这个理论才发展出这个理论的。
So, you're a Pelham, and you got into a relationship with the woman named Poland. Poland, and we are very different in most other ways. That's about as much as I'll say about that. Are you saying that the names played some kind of a role? I have to think it did. I have to think. And we were from different backgrounds, different religions. I mean, we come from very different worlds. And yet I was very attracted to her. So, where she actually was attracted to me, right? Yeah. So, I understand why you would sort of call this charming. And I think if you do this work for a while, there is a certain smile that comes to your face as you sort of look at these connections and you sort of see, you understand sort of the choices that human beings make.
所以，你姓佩拉姆，然后你和一个叫波兰的女性谈恋爱。波兰，我们在大多数其他方面都非常不同。关于这一点我就说这么多了。你是说名字在其中起了一定的作用吗？我不得不认为有。我不得不这样认为。而且我们来自不同的背景，不同的宗教。我的意思是，我们来自截然不同的世界。然而我却非常被她吸引。所以，她其实也被我吸引了，对吧？是的。所以，我理解为什么你会把这称作迷人。我想如果你做这种研究一段时间，当你审视这些联系并看到、理解人类所做出的选择时，你的脸上会浮现出一种微笑。
But I do think there's something disturbing about it because I think there is a very strong sense that I think most of us have. I have the sense, even though I've been covering the world of the unconscious mind for the last 10 years, I have the sense that my choices are deliberate choices, that I've thought about them, I've actually making them intentional. I'm making them intentionally.
但我确实认为这里面有些令人不安的东西，因为我认为我们大多数人心中都有非常强烈的一种感觉。我有一种感觉，尽管过去10年来我一直在报道无意识思维的世界，但我依然觉得我的选择是经过深思熟虑的，是我思考过的，是我真正有意识做出的。我是有意识地做出这些决择的。
And the idea that you're coming in and telling me that they're these hidden factors that come in and change how I think about myself, it is a disturbing idea. It is a little bit disturbing. And of course, most people do what you and I do, I do which is say well of course that applies to the rest of the world but I in particular would never fall prey to implicit racial bias from implicit egotism. So most of us do tend to sort of separate ourselves from even our own findings
而你跑来告诉我，说有一些隐藏的因素介入并改变了我对自己看法的时候，这真是一个令人不安的想法。这确实有点让人不安。当然，大多数人都做着你和我一样的事，那就是说：当然，这适用于世界上其他人，但我本人绝不会沦为内隐种族偏见、内隐自负的牺牲品。所以我们大多数人确实倾向于把自己与甚至是我们自己的发现隔离开来。
but I've become in the past decade or so comfortable enough with the study that I have to admit that I really never know for sure exactly why I did something. I mean sometimes I have a pretty good idea, but I certainly don't kid myself anymore to say that I even usually know why I do what I do. I mean there's just too much research, much of which you documented and reported on that shows that biases were completely unaware of, not just sometimes powerfully drive us in very particular direction.
但在过去十年左右的时间里，我对这项研究已经习以为常，我不得不承认，我真的永远无法确切知道自己为什么要做出某种行为。我的意思是，有时我有一个相当不错的想法，但我肯定不再自欺欺人了，不敢说我甚至通常都知道自己为什么要做自己所做的事。我的意思是，有太多的研究——其中许多你都记录并报道过——表明我们完全没有意识到的偏见，不仅在某些时候，而且在非常特定的方向上强有力地驱使着我们。
So I think I've just kind of let go of it. It was disturbing to me when I first began to study it, disturbing as well as delightful, and now it's become more delightful and less disturbing. So perhaps you're wondering, how does any of this matter? Who cares if people born on the 23rd of September marry those born on the 23rd of July? Who cares if someone named Betsy Carpenter gravitates towards Carpentry? Why does it matter if I prefer a philosopher whose name is similar to my own? It at least raises tough questions about the degree to which we have free will.
所以我想我已经有点释怀了。当我刚开始研究它时，它让我感到不安，既不安又愉快，而现在它变得更加愉快而不再那么不安。所以你可能在想，这有什么关系呢？9月23日出生的人和7月23日出生的人结婚，这有什么关系呢？一个叫贝茨·卡彭特的人倾向于从事木工工作，这重要吗？如果我偏爱一个名字与我自己相似的哲学家，这重要吗？这至少提出了一个关于我们拥有多少自由意志的艰难问题。
So I think some people who have pretty negative reactions to this work are very threatened by it in the sense that it suggests that very important decisions have at least a little nudging influence based on things that you're completely unaware of. So if people are more likely than they should be by chance to marry another person who happens to share their birthday number, that's not an objectively great reason to get married. You should get married because you share values. You're both Republicans.
所以我想，对这项研究有相当负面反应的一些人会感到受到了极大的威胁，因为它暗示了那些非常重要的决定，至少受到了一点点基于你完全没有意识到的因素的隐秘影响。因此，如果人们结婚时比随机概率更有可能选择与自己生日数字相同的人，那并不是一个客观上绝佳的结婚理由。你们结婚应该是因为你们有共同的价值观。你们都是共和党人。
You're both rabid Marxists. But learning that these subtle little influences can affect what you do, apparently to some people is I find it delightful, but some people find it pretty threatening. I don't think that it proves that there's no such thing as free will, but it, to me, it does suggest that we don't always have free will. Sometimes we make a decision for one reason that we told ourselves when really the more powerful underlying reason is something we could have never put our fingers on.
你们都是狂热的马克思主义者。但得知这些微小的潜移默化影响会影响你的行为——显然对某些人来说……我觉得这很有趣，但有些人却觉得这相当具有威胁性。我不认为这证明了自由意志不存在，但对我来说，它确实表明我们并不总是拥有自由意志。有时我们因为一个告诉自己的理由而做出决定，而实际上更强大、更深层的理由是我们永远无法触及的。
And this isn't just a matter of being drawn to someone who shares your birthday. In general, we tend to prefer things and people who have something to do with us. And that can be a big problem. Absolutely. I do a little bit of research on social justice, and that's one of the things that concerns we know is that we tend to focus on people who are more like us, who speak our language, who speak our idiom, who look like us, who worship like us, and we pay much less attention sadly to the problems of people who don't.
这不仅仅是被与你共享生日的人吸引的问题。总的来说，我们往往更喜欢与我们有关的事物和人。这可能会成为一个大问题。完全正确。我做过一点关于社会正义的研究，这也是让我担忧的事情之一，我们往往把注意力集中在那些更像我们的人身上，他们说我们的语言，说我们的方言，长得像我们，有和我们一样的信仰，而可悲的是，我们对那些与我们不同的人所面临的问题却关注得少得多。
On the other hand, I think this finding, like any finding in psychology or behavioral economics can be used for good or evil, and the way it works in the world can be used for good or bad. And so a great example that I perceive as at least a cousin of implicit negatism is a study I think was done by Elliot Smith and colleagues about 10 years ago. He looked at implicit racial bias, and he looked at implicit racial bias as a function of whether a person from a different ethnic group I think he had whites in African-Americans for example had simply given you a gentle friendly touch on the shoulder.
另一方面，我认为这一发现，就像心理学或行为经济学中的任何发现一样，既可以用于善意也可以用于邪恶，它在世界上的运作方式可以带来好结果也可以带来坏结果。我所感知到的一个很好的例子，至少是内隐自负的近亲，是埃利奥特·史密斯（Elliot Smith）及其同事在大约10年前做的一项研究。他研究了内隐种族偏见，他将内隐种族偏见视为一种函数，考察来自不同族裔群体的人——我想他以白人和非裔美国人为例——是否仅仅对你进行了友善温和的肩膀触碰。
And if they had given you a friendly gentle, hello, how are you touch? That reduced their implicit racial bias. So to me, when another person becomes a part of you, in a very tiny way, you play in Chimiel basketball with this person, and you didn't like his group, but now that you meet him, and he's on your team, suddenly he becomes a part of you,
如果他们对你进行了友好温和的“你好，最近怎么样”式的触碰，这就会减少他们的内隐种族偏见。所以对我来说，当另一个人以非常微小的方式成为你的一部分时，你和这个人一起打过 intramural 篮球，虽然你以前不喜欢他的群体，但现在你遇到了他，他加入了你的团队，突然之间他成了你的一部分，
his group becomes a part of you, and your stereotypes get softened and diminished a little bit. When we come back, we're going to look at how the Narcissus effect shapes another important part of your life. If you can fall in love with your name or your birthday, can't you also fall in love with your own ideas, your own work? Of course you can.
他的群体成了你的一部分，你的刻板印象就会稍微软化和减弱。当我们回来时，我们将探讨纳喀索斯效应如何塑造你生活的另一个重要部分。如果你能爱上自己的名字或生日，难道你不能也爱上自己的想法、自己的工作吗？当然可以。
Researchers call this the IKEA effect. We come to overvalue the things that we have created ourselves. We'll also look at the implications this can have for things much bigger and much more complicated than Swedish furniture. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. The actress Amy Polar once said, IKEA is Swedish for argument. Research a Daniel Mochon has one explanation for why build it yourself furniture can cause
研究人员称之为“宜家效应”（IKEA effect）。我们会过度评价我们自己创造的东西。我们还将探讨这对那些比瑞典家具大得多、复杂得多的事情可能产生的影响。请不要离开。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。女演员艾米·波勒（Amy Poehler）曾说过，宜家在瑞典语里是“争吵”的意思。研究人员丹尼尔·莫雄（Daniel Mochon）对为什么“自己动手组装”的家具会引起
so much friction between partners. Imagine that you built a table, maybe came out a little bit crooked. Probably your wife or your neighbor would see it for what it is, you know, probably a shoddy piece of workmanship. But to you that table might seem really great. Because you're the one who created it. It is the fruit of your labor. And that is really the idea behind the A key effect. It is that we come to overvalue the things that we have created ourselves. Brett Palem's research about our preference for people and places that are associated with us made me think about a related idea. The narcissus effect also shows up in
伴侣之间如此多的摩擦给出了一个解释。想象一下，你组装了一张桌子，做出来可能有点歪。可能你的妻子或邻居会看出它的本来面目，你知道，那可能是一件做工劣质的产品。但对你来说，那张桌子可能会显得非常棒。因为你是创造它的人。它是你劳动的果实。这正是宜家效应背后的理念。那就是我们往往会过度评价我们自己创造的东西。布雷特·佩拉姆关于我们对与我们相关的人和地点的偏好的研究，让我想到了一个相关的想法。纳喀索斯效应也表现在
our preference for things that we make ourselves. The way people usually think about IKEA is that IKEA gives you good furniture for low cost because they offload lots of the costs onto their consumers, the assembly costs. But in fact, we were in a sense challenging that idea and saying that this is actually psychological benefit behind this, that actually people might end up liking their furniture more because they built it. And so it's not so much a cost, but a benefit that they get to build their own furniture.
我们对亲手制作的东西的偏好上。人们通常对宜家的看法是，宜家以低成本为你提供优质家具，因为他们将许多成本转嫁给了消费者，也就是组装成本。但事实上，我们在某种程度上是在挑战这种观点，并认为这背后其实有心理益处，实际上人们可能最终更喜欢他们的家具，因为是他们自己组装的。所以与其说这是个成本，不如说这是他们自己组装家具所获得的益处。
Daniel and his co-authors did a series of experiments to test this hypothesis. They brought volunteers into the lab and gave them either a Lego car pre-assembled or gave them Legos and instructions and To all the participants to build a car themselves Then they asked the volunteers how much would you pay to keep you a Lego car? And what we fight is that the people who build their own Legos Not only are willing to pay more to keep their assembled Legos
丹尼尔和他的合著者做了一系列实验来检验这个假设。他们把志愿者带到实验室，给他们一辆预先组装好的乐高汽车，或者给他们乐高积木和说明书，并让所有参与者自己组装一辆汽车。然后他们问志愿者：为了保留这辆乐高汽车，你愿意付多少钱？我们发现的是，那些自己组装乐高的人不仅愿意花更多的钱来保留他们组装好的乐高，
But also when we ask them how proud they are of their own creations, they tend to be prouder of their Legos. In mind, these are Legos that are designed to 5 to 7 year olds, but nonetheless, it seems to be some competence and some pride associated with one's creation, even for basic things as building Legos. The researchers replicated the study using other products, like IKEA furniture and the effect was the same. People who spent time and effort building something felt proud of what they'd built, felt in love with it, and were willing to pay lots of money to keep the things they'd built. From the perspective of a rational economist, this doesn't make much sense. The students might be willing to pay twice as much money
而且当我们问他们对自己创造的成果感到多么骄傲时，他们往往对自己的乐高更加自豪。请记住，这些是为5到7岁儿童设计的乐高玩具，但尽管如此，即使是对于组装乐高这样基础的事情，似乎也伴随着某种胜任感和自豪感。研究人员使用其他产品（如宜家家具）复制了这项研究，结果是一样的。花时间和精力组装东西的人会对他们建造的东西感到自豪，爱上它，并愿意花大把的钱来保留他们建造的东西。从理性经济学家的角度来看，这毫无意义。学生们可能愿意花双倍的钱
to buy the exact same Lego car. If they just finished building that Lego car, then if the Lego car was given to them pre-built. So why might people value something more after building it themselves compared to buying the same product made by someone else for half the cost? Our hypothesis was that people tend to use products to signal valued identities to both themselves and to others.
去买一模一样的乐高汽车。如果他们刚刚组装好那辆乐高汽车，那么与直接把预先组装好的乐高汽车送给他们相比。那么，为什么人们在自己动手组装后，会比花半价购买别人制作的相同产品赋予更高的价值呢？我们的假设是，人们倾向于利用产品向自己和他人发出有价值的身份信号。
We know that an identity that people really care about is showing that they're competent. This is one of the basics of human motivation. We hypothesize that people use self-made products as a way to signal competence to both themselves and to others. Having just built a table or having just built a bookcase. That bookcase has completed products in a sense of a badge of my own personal competence. I completed it, therefore I know I'm a competent person. And more I can display this product and signal that identity, this competent identity to others. And so
我们知道，人们非常关心的一个身份就是展示他们的胜任能力。这是人类动机的基础之一。我们假设人们使用自己制作的产品作为向自己和他人发出胜任能力信号的一种方式。刚刚组装好一张桌子或刚刚组装好一个书柜。从某种意义上说，那个书柜完成的产品就是我个人胜任能力的一个徽章。我完成了它，因此我知道自己是一个有能力的人。而且我可以更多地展示这个产品，并向他人发出这种身份信号，这种有胜任能力的身份。所以
we hypothesized that it was these feelings of competence associated with the products that led to their increasing valuation. To test the theory that people's feelings of competence was behind the IKEA effect, the researchers had some participants think about other qualities they might value in themselves, besides competence, things like honesty or intelligence or humor. Basically, the idea was, if we make it less important for people to demonstrate competence, do they still overvalue their own creations? So we found that the key effect disappeared when we did that manipulation. So once competence
我们假设，正是与这些产品相关的胜任感导致了它们价值的提升。为了检验“人们的胜任感是宜家效应背后的原因”这一理论，研究人员让一些参与者思考他们在自己身上可能看重的除胜任能力之外的其他品质，比如诚实、智慧或幽默。基本上，这个想法是，如果我们降低人们展示胜任能力的重要性，他们还会过度评价自己的创造吗？所以我们发现，当我们进行这种操纵时，宜家效应消失了。因此，一旦胜任能力
wasn't that important to people, people, our participants no longer seem to get much valid of creating their own products. Again against suggesting that the reason why we tend to like our own creations is because we use them as a way to signal competence both to ourselves and to others. Here is the flip side of that coin. You can make the IKEA effects stronger by getting people to question their competence. In one experiment, Daniel and his colleagues gave participants math problems to Saul before asking them to build an IKEA project. If the problems were difficult, lots of people failed to solve them. Now, volunteers became much more likely to want to demonstrate their competence through the IKEA building project.
对人们不再那么重要，人们——我们的参与者——似乎就不再从自己制造的产品中获得多少价值了。这再次表明，我们倾向于喜欢自己的创造的原因，是因为我们把它们作为向自己和他人发出胜任能力信号的一种方式。硬币的另一面是这样的。你可以通过让人对自己的胜任能力产生质疑来增强宜家效应。在一个实验中，丹尼尔和他的同事在要求参与者组装宜家项目之前，让他们解答数学题。如果题目很难，很多人都没能解出来。现在，志愿者们变得更有可能想要通过宜家建造项目来展示他们的胜任能力。
The participants who at least temporarily had their sense of competence threatened who got a very difficult math questions, tended to be more willing to build their own product. So when we survey them and ask them, would you prefer to have an IKEA product that comes pre-built or the exact same product that comes unbuilt and you would build it yourself? Those who had got difficult math problems and were feeling somewhat incompetent at the time, seemed more willing. They were much more likely to want to build a product themselves. And therefore, in a sense, restore their sense of competence through this activity. I mean, give me the number, Sarah.
那些胜任感至少暂时受到威胁、做出了非常困难的数学题的参与者，往往更愿意自己组装产品。所以当我们对他们进行调查并问他们：“你更喜欢买预先组装好的宜家产品，还是买完全相同但需要你自己动手的未组装产品？”那些做过困难数学题、当时感到有些无能的人，似乎更愿意。他们更有可能想要自己组装产品。因此，从某种意义上说，他们通过这项活动恢复了他们的胜任感。我的意思是，给我个具体数字，萨拉。
I mean, was this a big effect? Was this a small effect? I mean, what happens when people feel bad compared to when they don't feel bad? So, what we found is that about a third of the people wanted to build the IKEA bookshelf in the control condition when they weren't made to feel bad, and this number went up to about 60% when they were made to feel bad. So significantly larger number of people wanted to do this. The IKEA effect and implicit ecotism might seem at first first blush to be interesting and amusing, but not terribly significant. But the more I thought about this, the more I saw the potential implications. Just as we can be drawn to those who have the same birth they as us or the same name as
我的意思是，这是一个大效应吗？这是一个小效应吗？我的意思是，当人们感觉不好时与感觉好时相比会发生什么？所以，我们发现，大约有三分之一的人在对照组中、也就是没有让他们感觉不好时，想要组装宜家书架，而当他们被弄得感觉不好时，这个数字上升到了大约60%。所以有显著更多的人想要这样做。宜家效应和内隐自负乍一看可能有趣且好笑，但并非极其重要。但我想得越多，就越能看到其潜在的影响。正如我们会被那些与我们同一天生日或与我们同名的人吸引一样，
us, we might also be more inclined to help people who look like us, or sound like us, or live near us. Let's hear a congressperson who's drafted a particular piece of legislation, your commitment to that bill might outweigh its importance to the public. Or let's say you're a president who starts a war, after years of investing your time and effort to prosecute that war, you may find it difficult to accept evidence that you made a mistake. It's fine to gaze lovingly in the mirror and to feel invested in our own ideas, but like Narcissus discovered himself, falling in love with our own reflection can come at great peril.
我们可能也更倾向于帮助那些长得像我们、听起来像我们或住在我们附近的人。让我们听听一位起草特定立法议案的国会议员的话，你对该法案的承诺可能超过了它对公众的重要性。或者假设你是一位发动战争的总统，在投入数年时间和精力来推行这场战争之后，你可能会发现自己很难接受你犯了错误的证据。深情地凝视镜子并投资于我们自己的想法是没有问题的，但正如纳喀索斯自己所发现的那样，爱上我们自己的倒影可能会带来巨大的危险。
This episode was produced by Maggie Penman. Our team includes Tara Boyle, Jenny Schmidt, Parts Shah, Raina Cohen, Laura Quarelle and Thomas Lu. Our unsung hero this week is Andy Huther. Andy is the audio engineer for podcasting at NPR. He is always willing to pitch into help. When we have questions about sound design or the right microphone to use or how to make voices sound good in the studio, Andy always has good advice.
本期节目由玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）制作。我们的团队包括塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）、珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、帕茨·沙阿（Parts Shah）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、劳拉·夸雷莱（Laura Quarelle）和托马斯·刘（Thomas Lu）。我们本周的无名英雄是安迪·胡瑟（Andy Huther）。安迪是NPR播客的音频工程师。他总是乐于出手相助。当我们对声音设计、使用合适的麦克风或如何在录音室里让声音听起来更好有疑问时，安迪总是能给出很好的建议。
Thanks so much Andy. If you liked this episode, please be sure to share it with a friend. If they don't know how to subscribe to Hidden Brain, please show them. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢安迪。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必与朋友分享。如果他们不知道如何订阅《隐藏的大脑》，请教教他们。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。转录文本中还没有针对这一集的评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。